Ramadan is a month of Miracles no one
can explain how it happens but during
any other month of the year if you were
to Gorge yourself with food multiple
times per day anyone on planet reality
would say that you're feasting not
fasting and yet during the month of
Ramadan AKA opposite month gorging
yourself with food multiple times per
day is fasting not feasting this is what
I call the miracle of the dis appearing
e just as taking the E out of Shame
leaves you a sham just as taking the E
out of Fate leaves you fat so also
taking the E out of feasting leaves you
fasting of course if you think that
removing an E from a word somehow Alters
reality you have no shame and it's your
fate to turn into a fat fake fasting
sham but I'll give you an e for effort
it should be obvious by now that Ramadan
fasting and and I have had our
differences in the past and yet here I
am fasting during the month of Ramadan
even though I'm a Christian and I mean
that seriously for once I'm actually
fasting for Ramadan I'm not doing what I
would consider fasting but I am doing
Islamic fasting so why am I fasting for
Ramadan am I extending an olive branch
after so many years of criticizing
Muhammad and the Quran on not at all in
fact I'm about to start phase two of my
work if you liked phase one you're going
to love phase two if you didn't like
phase one you're really really not going
to like phase two but more on that when
you're least expecting it so if I'm not
extending an olive branch why am I
fasting for Ramadan well I mentioned in
some video a year or two ago that I have
an odd schedule and that if I were to
shift my schedule slightly I would be
doing Islamic fasting since then my
schedule has shifted so Islamic fasting
is now my normal life as many of you
know I have a son with special needs I
stay up with him at night and I sleep
during the day I eat dinner my last meal
of the day around 5:00 a.m. I go to
sleep around 8:00 or 9 in the morning I
wake up around 4: in the afternoon I do
a few things and then I make sure I eat
something before we go live at
night what does this mean it means that
my normal everyday life is yearr round
Islamic fasting there are a few
differences between what I do and what
our Muslim friends do one again I don't
consider this fasting I'm just eating on
a different schedule which is what
Ramadan fasting is it's eating on a
different
schedule two Studies have shown that our
Muslim friends consume significantly
more calories during Ramadan their month
of fasting than during other months I
don't because this is year round for me
so I just eat my normal
calories three I don't run around saying
hey everyone look at me I'm
fasting I'm bringing it up in this video
to make a point but ordinarily I
wouldn't consider it worth mentioning I
would regard myself as a total hypocrite
if I gorged myself with food multiple
times per day and claimed that I'm
fasting apart from that in The Sermon on
the Mount Jesus warned his followers to
be very careful about drawing attention
to ourselves for doing good deeds he
said be careful not to practice your
righteousness in front of others to be
seen by them if you do you will have no
reward from your father in Heaven he
warned us about giving to the needy to
be seen by others he warned us about
praying to be seen by others and he
warned us about fasting real fasting not
Islamic fasting to be seen by others if
you're giving to the needy or praying or
fasting so that people look at you and
say what a righteous person don't expect
any reward from God you have your
reward in Islam pretty much everything
is me to be seen by others look at me
when I'm praying look at me when I'm
fasting look at what I'm wearing I want
attention attention attention
attention if you took everything Jesus
said about what not to do and you rolled
it all up into a great big ball you'd
get
Islam so I'll be doing my Ramadan
fasting a little differently but I'm
happy to say to all my Muslim friends
out there that I'm with you for
Ramadan just as you're not eating during
the day I won't be eating during the day
so if at any point this month you find
yourself thinking wow this is really
hard just remember that your old pal
dwood is fasting year round without ever
being even slightly bothered because
it's really not hard at all it's just
changing your eating schedule
Ramadan Mubarak now let's have some fun
this month
[Music]